Europe's Western Front is the setting as
european union leaders prepare to mark
the centenary of World War One up to
400,000 soldiers lost their lives in the
wide open and often Maddie flatlands
around the Belgian town of e / almost
half were from British Commonwealth
countries Belgians French and of course
Germans died in Flanders Fields to the
leaders are gathering at the menin gate
a memorial on the main road where
soldiers headed to battle many never to
return it will be a moving ceremony
because we are here at testifying what
Europe is a project of peace a project
of solidarity a project of cooperation
we are not perfect but for many people
outside Europe we are still a model a
model of Peace of democracy of
prosperity and of social protection this
shrine ensures that the soldiers who
went missing in wartime will always be
remembered their names are here even
though their bodies are not indeed the
remains of around 30 soldiers are still
discovered in the fields of the Western
Front each year a century after the war
the director of the organization that
manages this site says the leaders could
not have chosen a better spot can't
think of a more appropriate place for
them to gather the men in gates the
memorial to the missing it was the first
memorial to the missing and it
commemorates 55,000 casualties or the
First World War for whom we do not know
where they are buried to mark the
occasion the European Union is donating
a symbolic bench where people can come
to sit and remember bronzed copper
plates are stamped with the word peace
in the e use twenty four official
languages in the shaded place next to
the menin gate the leaders will plant
ceramic flowers the ceremony on jun 26th
will also include the playing of the
last post the traditional final military
salute to the fallen the last post is
sounded under the menin gate every
evening tourists veterans and service
men and women from around the world
gather to watch to lay wreaths or simply
to pay their respects in silence with
the inauguration of the menin gate in
1927 for the first time the last post
has been sounded and this made such an
impact on all the people attending the
ceremony and also the e / citizens so
from 1928 on we began with our ceremony
until now without fault except during
the Second World War for buglers from
the fire brigade usually play the last
post two teams alternate each week
Oh
Tony distort has been taking part in the
ceremony for 19 years as a child the
moving strains of the last post reached
his window each night by the age of 14
he'd learned to play it in full you see
the emotion every everyday people cry
and when we self we come to hear it when
we are not on duty we even get some
goose bumps but when we do it on our own
we don't have so many feelings that we
just focus on the last post
World War 1 ravaged lives families and
the very land itself more than 150
cemeteries lies scattered around eeper
many mass graves remain in silent
testimony to a land so thoroughly
scarred by battle a century ago work
continues even today the constant
refurbishing of headstones some 22,000
every year keeping memories alive life
in Europe goes on but the conflict in
Ukraine and the rise of extremist
parties are a stark reminder of how
little it would take to turn back the
clock of how easy it can be to forget
we're very proud to look after the
cemeteries and memorials that we do care
for but I think let's not have cause to
build anymore we have enough and and
these memorials themselves are I think
the best demonstration of why we should
avoid war at all costs so how wonderful
is that all the heads of government of
Europe where we had the two world wars
are gathering here having that hugely
significant and poignant and appropriate
you
you